when we met I think you were making
about a thousand pounds a month passive
income from YouTube yes that's correct
now you're making three thousand eight
hundred and over the last sort of 10
months since you've been on the academy
how many properties have you acquired to
your portfolio four
excellent two in it the traditional way
will take for years you can't wait for
every traffic light to be on green
before you leave the house I don't know
how you draw these lovely people
I've met anybody that I can say I don't
like everyone's amazing best piece of
advice would be get the education Rome
wasn't built in a day
okay this is gonna work and I have to
make it work and it will work you think
when you find a deal all your problems
are going to be over because you found a
deal no you're probably just beginning
if you work with other people you can
reach your goals a lot faster
opportunities only come back once
[Music]
Sandra Reed International property
investor and developer financially free
have been in the game for how many years
20. 20 plus 20 plus years it sounds very
impressive thank you what was your
background of property when we met you
had like two houses so background really
is my father he was a property investor
developer yeah he helped a lot of people
to develop his houses or their houses in
Jamaica so I kind of watched his growth
he owned a lot of houses in the Brixton
area
so every time with my children I'll say
your granddad owned that Granddad own
that wow because he had quite a big
portfolio in um Brixton so she was in
the blood probably in the blood it's
taken me a bit of time but yeah it's in
the blood so you started getting into
property buying houses what was the
problem what was the challenge what took
you so long before things started
because now you've got a lot of
properties you're controlling lots of
properties things are going well you're
full-time investor but for like 20 years
you were just struggling with property I
was struggling I think because I was
working I'm trying to run a business I
started my business as a virtual pa
um I think 12 12 years ago and so I
started doing that the first house that
I bought
I just rented it out when I lived abroad
I lived in Bermuda and Jamaica for a
period of time and that's how I started
renting out that property
um never returned the thing that I did
which wasn't good and I've learned from
you now is that I was boring to pay off
other debts and so the
um the investment that I had started to
get less and less yeah so when I
actually really wanted to borrow to
purchase another property a few years
ago we had to extend the lease which
cost like 50 odd thousand pounds so that
kind of wiped out trying to buy another
property and kind of start from there
lending from the equity to to start
purchasing so that kind of slowed slowed
us down and got a bit frustrated as
someone that's been in the game for a
long time and your father who was a
successful property investor and
developer what do you think about when
people say forget all the creative
strategies like rent to rent and lease
options and digital selling that's all
nonsense just work hard save money and
buy a house which is what you were
effectively doing what do you think of
this traditional Sloan steady way of
just buying houses and accumulating them
with the savings from your job that
would take years yeah and it will take
years and years for you to do that which
is what you were attempting to do yeah
which is what I was attempting to do it
will take years so what I've learned now
is to borrow other people's money yeah
to be able to increase
um and also work with other people JV
because you can't do everything on your
own so definitely doing it the
traditional way will take for years
because if you think about it if you
need 25 to deposit it and the average
house is 300 Grand that's 75 grand that
doesn't take into account stamp Duty
legals so best part of 100 Grand to buy
a house absolutely and you had two and
you were making when we met I think you
were making about a thousand pounds a
month passive income from YouTube buy
today yes that's correct now you're
making 3800 from your other properties
yeah so talk to me how did we meet how
did you change your strategy yeah what
happened okay so I recall I think 2021 I
believe I don't know how you came up you
popped up on YouTube and I saw the
um the live course he was doing and I
thought okay let's this is interesting I
thought I was going to be bored and I
was mesmerized I was just I think it's
like from I think it's 10 o'clock in the
morning and it went right back till 10
o'clock at night and I was like
mesmerized it was just really
interesting you just gave it a lot of
energy it was interesting and then I
thought okay well what's going to be my
next step I need to find out a bit more
about because actually being out of
property although I was in property I
wasn't really concentrating on
increasing my portfolio I was doing
other things and then covid came and so
I thought well what do I need to do now
to educate myself I don't know what's
going on in the property game at the
moment so going on your course at the
time was great and then I decided to do
your course where you come to your house
and I thought that would be the best way
to start because then you would be able
to guide me and tell me what I need to
do and then I started the course I went
on the HMO the boot camp one I went on
in Birmingham and I decided to purchase
a course I just thought okay I'm gonna
do this this
is going to work and I have to make it
work and it will work and I just love
the energy I love the course I love the
people I loved meeting different people
it was amazing honestly and I've been
working from home for a long time so I
haven't really been out and about and I
thought I need to come out my comfort
zone now and really get out and about
and meet different people because I
can't run a business from home and not
meet people so that was one of the
reasons why it forced me to come out my
comfort zone it forced me to go out
every month to attend your courses the
live sessions and then when you
registered for a bunch of different
courses you ended up joining the academy
yes which is 12 months of mentoring and
support how did you afford to go on all
those courses because they're not cheap
you know they're not worth 100 pounds
it's like thousands of pounds how do you
afford to get the financing Place bounce
back loan came in very handy okay so
you've got a loan yeah went on the
courses we're not worried we're not
thinking like I've got to pay back this
loan at some point what happens if it
doesn't work no I don't everything I
don't think positive negative like that
sorry I never think never too it has to
work if I've taken the time to spend the
money then I have to make it work for me
and what's the experience been like
how's it been like working with me and
the team over the last year or so it's
been fantastic the support has been
there
um coming to the courses I've learned a
lot it's important to have the right
education because
there's good there's do's and don'ts in
any business so it's great to know what
you can do from what you can't do
because I'm a Believer to do things
properly right I like to do things
properly the right way and over the last
sort of 10 months since you've been on
the academy how many properties have you
acquired to your portfolio four four
excellent so you doubled it yeah and how
much you were making a thousand pounds a
month from property how much you're
making now so it's roughly about three
eight three thousand eight hundred in
total so you've added an extra 2 800
approximately on your portfolio and now
you're full-time in property yes how
does it feel great love it what does an
average day look like for Sandra
beverage day I suppose it's managing all
the properties making sure that they're
all running okay
um checking emails
um
getting tenants in
advertising going to the sa if I need to
and make sure that the sheets are
changed although I don't have to do that
anymore I did in the beginning so I've
now got someone that manages two of
those properties the essays I'm
currently hoping to get another one of
which is going to be local to me so I'll
manage that one
so yeah it's life is very busy I've
actually got another project coming
which is a family project which is a
loft conversion that's going to start
next month so
my heads and you're doing stuff now in
the Caribbean yes in fact we spent a
couple weeks in the Caribbean last month
yes we did yes we did you know hanging
out doing different things so we've got
a lot of stuff in the background in the
Caribbean but now you know you're
financially independent yes making a
good income what of being the areas that
you've been working in in terms of your
property portfolio Okay I remember the
advice from you when I first came to
your house and you said oh just do your
area yeah and so that is what I tried to
do but I've been finding it very
difficult because London's expensive
so I've actually gone all over the place
that wasn't the strategy but I've got
Liverpool two in Liverpool
um one in Canterbury another in London
so I'm a bit all over the place but okay
I thought if I'm gonna sit and wait for
London it might never happen so just to
take the opportunities and run with it
and how do you find the management side
of things when you've got properties in
Liverpool what happens if there's a
problem or an issue how do you deal with
it so I've got a management company who
has been in the academy who has now set
up his own management company so he's he
has an invested interest as well because
he has his own essays so he's actually
managing those two essays forms that's
the thing right it's all about team
isn't it so when we're in in the
Caribbean for a couple weeks yeah you
know we need to make sure that
everything's all systemized and set up
in the UK yeah so what tips would you
give to people in terms of finding
managers finding cleaners because that's
part of the difficult part right people
think the hard bit is getting the deal
people say to me I can't find a deal I
can't want to do it's like you think
when you find a deal all your problems
are going to be over because you found
it out no you're probably just don't get
it then the next problem is going to be
oh now I need to Stage the property and
get the furniture and then the next
problem is going to be now I can't find
a good team to manage it you're gonna
have problems all the way definitely and
that's why you need to be trained and
you need good connections and you need
mentors and new communities you know
you're on the Mastermind every week yeah
if you've ever got a problem you shout
it out and everyone pulls in to help and
that's what it's about so what advice
could you give people in terms of
Management Systems procedures to give
them the best of the Head Start when
they get started property having the
knowledge number one having the
knowledge to know what you need to do if
there if problems do arise we have a
community of people that have different
levels of experience to lean on them
Oxford advice and get support within the
community because most of the people are
either doing it themselves or want to do
it so there's if you network with other
people they may be able to find you
cleaners they might be able to find you
management a management company which is
what I did I just worked within the
community to get the management company
and if they have an invested interest
already then nine times out of ten then
you should be okay that they will look
after you as well so yeah just work
within your community to to help you
find all the different teamwork of
people that can help support your
business because I think you have to let
go you can't you can't do everything
yourself yeah um I've done some of the
work myself I know what I need to do I
know no one can't fool me I'll pull the
wool over my eyes so now I can hand it
over and feel quite comfortable that
okay well where's the link to the
property and check for myself where how
many times it's been booked and so forth
so when I get a report every month then
you know I feel comfortable and your
properties are mostly hmos so I've got
two hmos and two essays okay cool um and
two byte to lets so six properties in
total yeah
um that's incredible yeah and stuff
going on in Jamaica yeah so what would
you say is the hobby the hardest thing
about like getting your properties
finding the landlords the whole business
what's been the hardest the hardest
aspect I think it's just being
consistent because sometimes life can
drag you
to do other things they're just really
trying to be consistent all the time
which is not always easy to make the
phone calls to the landlords and doing
your research and finding the properties
I think for me the hardest has been
consistency
I've had a few issues with landlords
where they've just been unpredictable so
I've always found a comfort in calling
um the helpline or the mentorship and
getting advice from the team just so it
makes me know that I'm doing the right
thing
um to be honest
I can't
I've not found anything difficult maybe
it's my personality I really can't say I
found anything difficult I just roll
with things I don't ever think
things are going to stop me from moving
to the next level yeah yeah you have a
challenge I just get on with it I don't
I don't moan or whatever to people I
just if I've got a challenge I know that
I can call the mentorship and say okay
this is my issue what do I need to do
that's it I just don't worry about
things I just do what I need to do I
think that's a lot of people's problems
they over worry about things they're
worrying about problems that have never
happened some people say to me what do
you do in the situation that this
happens and the Tenant does this I'm
thinking have that happened to you they
go no well why yeah are you worried
about it yeah what do you want to do is
you want to crack on with your business
and then when the problem arises then
figure out how to fix it absolutely
because you can't necessarily be
prepared for every single eventuality
you can't wait for every traffic like to
be on green before you leave the house
absolutely you know so talk to me about
the importance of people around you that
are also doing deals and are successful
because we really believe in the academy
that environment is really important
that is very important because if
someone else is doing I mean you we're
all doing well in our own way but we'll
always think oh well they're doing
better than us or how come I haven't had
my time yet you know I've had the little
thought in my head and I'm thinking no
Sandra things will come to you in your
time it's just to put yourself
out there do go to the the networking
events every month if you can speak to
people which I don't often do I must
admit I kind of stick to the people that
I know and I know that's
that's just that's just me and I need to
come out of my comfort zone a bit more
but just to really
um keep in contact with your community
with me friends and family apart from my
husband and my children I don't really
Converse outside of that when it comes
to property and what I'm doing so very
important to to stick with those people
that are doing the same thing as you
because you want to Aspire to those
people as well like yourself I want to
Aspire to be able to do what you're
doing yeah um so yeah it's very
important to have a circle of friends
that are doing what you're doing because
you have a an invested interest in each
other I mean your husband's amazing I
know he's do he did the training with
you yes and he's your business partner
your husband your kids as well are
amazing you've got two children um you
said that some of the other people in
your family you don't really speak to
them about about business why is that I
mean my mom's elderly she understands
you know but she's she's almost 90. so
I'll speak to her about what I'm doing
my brother well we kind of all jving
together with
the overseas project but I just it's
just it's just how I am I just found a
lot of jealousy over the years growing
up within my circle of people
um so I just kind of keep to myself yeah
and kind just focus on those people that
are doing the same as me because they
understand your journey have you made a
lot of friends within the Academy I have
I have good friends good friends I don't
know how you draw these lovely people
but
I've met anybody that I can say I don't
like everyone's amazing that I have met
you also um you sold you sold your first
deal when when did you sell your first
deal in 2019 okay tell me about that
that was a house in Brixton I think it
was a if I remember four bedroom house
four five bedroom house it was really
dilapidated and I did the leaflet
dropping
um wrote letters and on bright colored
um paper and just sent them around
houses that had for sale signs nine
times out of ten I always get called so
I got the call this gentleman his mother
died passed away passed the house onto
him and his siblings and they want to
get rid of so I went around there it was
a really bad State at the time I just
started my journey and me and the estate
agent hit it off and he said oh yes and
I do have an investor who would be
interested in buying because he buys all
the properties in that area
and that's how it went we he took the
house and we split the fee 50 50 I think
I got six grand I think it was 600 and
something 600 and something K we sold
the house for no so it was a 12 Grand
fee and then split it with the estate
agent and I got my show what are your
plans there now within property you've
got a bunch of rent to rent you've got
some buy to let where are you moving now
you've got the stuff that we're doing in
the Caribbean what's the plan So the
plan is this year to definitely buy
I don't think I want to increase on my
rent to rent I'm negotiating one now
I'd like to purchase now do brr
definitely that's the way to go so what
what do you think the best thing about
rent to rent is because you mentioned
that you don't necessarily want to scale
it
um one of the things I think is great
about rent to rents is that it will give
you the ability to go full time in
property yeah you've not got to worry
about money you've got your bills
covered you've got maybe three four five
rent to rent
um that's what I think the best thing
about renting yeah is giving you that
time Freedom initially
um what about yourself what the pros and
cons to do rent to rent the pros are as
you said you get the cash flow coming in
from each property
um the cons will be that you know you
might have signed a two year or
five-year agreement but the landlord
might change their mind decide to take
the property back so whereas you've got
this income coming in
um they could then turn around and say
they don't want to do the deal anymore
or there's only a limit to what you can
do to the house you don't want to spend
loads and loads of money on a house that
isn't yours yeah so you're limited to
what you can do to put your own self I
guess your own ideas into into a
property but I think it's great it's
helped me
um and not to say that I wouldn't
increase I just want to focus on
a property that I know it's mine but I I
don't know it's purpose yeah it's got to
the point where you financially free
yeah you you're full-time in property
yeah and now you're looking to to Really
build and scale yeah and how are you
going to do that what's your plan so
yeah just to look at in um auctions and
look in the cheapest areas maybe JV
possibly JV with somebody so it
increases
um the property that we can purchase
together and yeah maybe get two or three
by the end of the year no I just love
that so use other people's money grow
your network yeah but also continue to
increase your cash flow yes what will be
your best piece of advice people that
are wanting to maybe they've been in
property for 20 years like you but
they're wanting to really scale up their
cash flow and become financially free
what would be your best piece of advice
best piece of advice would be to get the
education because Rome wasn't built in a
day and we don't know everything doesn't
matter how young or old we are always
get the education and do things the
right way and yeah work with other
people because we I think as people we
tend to want to work and do things and
get the claim for ourselves but actually
if you work with other people
um you can reach your goals a lot faster
so JV in
um using other people's money
to help you Excel further to the next
level definitely but definitely
education get the education and work
with other people and what was it that
made you agree to come and sit down on
winners on a Wednesday because I'll be
I'll be asking you for a few months now
what was it that made you say you know
what I'm gonna do it opportunities only
come but once and so we have to grasp
every opportunity that comes because you
might not want to come and knock on my
door again so I thought okay let's do it
Sandra put everything aside let's do it
and you've done you've achieved enough
you've not achieved all your goals yet
obviously but if it inspires somebody
um then I've done my job
well I'm sure you will and I think
you've done an incredible job thank you
and I'm really looking forward to seeing
you continue to prosper continue to
build continue to win and I really
appreciate you coming and sharing your
story thank you very much it's been a
pleasure being here
[Music]